did you like come up in the like rap
scene in florida or did you like have to
go to atlanta where
um my [ __ ] just went viral um after i
realized welcome like a dog july 4th
2019 on soundcloud it did a million
plays in seven days and it was over [ __ ]
my life changed ever since then would
you say when you did that record you
would like had any intention to take
music seriously no never i never dreamed
of being a rapper i never wrote poems i
never did any of that [ __ ] my daddy used
to write when i was a kid but i always
even going through high school all of my
friends used to rap like my home was in
high school
i started to be like get out of here
like you're not going to be a rapper you
got to be little wayne a [ __ ] drink
of somebody it won't happen like that
yeah there's nobody who like looked like
you that was doing it yes so to be fair
i also think you're the first person i
know little nah's ex is gay yeah but i
feel like
you're like
flamboyant yes in a different way
is that is that appropriate to say yes
yeah it's cool because you know when
lanai's when we first met little knives
you know he was he we didn't know he was
uh yeah we didn't know he was we just he
just had the [ __ ] cowboy record yeah
yeah
i'm saying i think i'm the first one
that came out like you know what you see
is what you get you already know what
time it is you know when you see me
and um to be able to have the amount of
success that i have being like that you
know it's new it's different it's dope